uh my name is Daniel botsman I teach in
the history Department uh here at Yale
and it's a great pleasure to be able to
welcome you all today to Yale's 23rd
annual John W Hall lecture in Japanese
studies
uh as explained in these pamphlets that
hopefully you've all received
um the series uh the whole series was
established in 1999 with the generous
support of Mrs Robin Hall to honor the
memory of her husband John W Hall who
was of course one of the most important
figures in the development of Japanese
studies in the decades following World
War II
Professor Hall was a historian primarily
of pre-modern Japan who completed his
PhD dissertation at Harvard writing
about uh tanima okitsugu one of the
important uh political figures of the
18th century in Japan
and he wrote the dissertation under the
direction of Edwin O reichhauer he then
began his scholarly career at the
University of Michigan in 1949 before
moving to Yale in 1961 as the a Whitney
Griswold professor of history
as a scholar he played a critical role
in opening the study of pre-modern
Japanese history to the English-speaking
world with a slew of important Works
including most importantly perhaps his
1966 monograph government and local
power in Japan 500 to 1700 he also of
course edited the original Cambridge
history of Japan volumes an enduring
contribution to the field which is only
now in the process of being updated
for all of his deep engagement with the
past he was also very much an
institution Builder strongly committed
to the work of facilitating the
scholarship of the future
uh at Yale he was chair of the history
department and of the Council on East
Nation studies he was also Master as it
was then known of Morse college and he
trained a generation of graduate
students here who went on to reshape the
field including figures such as
hellbalifeo Jeffrey Mass James McLean
and Suzanne gay
outside of Yale he played a central role
in building the institutional structures
that have supported the study of Japan
and Asia more generally ever since
including the association for Asian
studies for example
each year then with the exception I will
say of 20 20 21 we took a little covert
break
Yale's current faculty have the
privilege of extending to an eminent
scholar of Japan an invitation to
deliver the whole lecture and we're
extremely fortunate this year to have
been able to convince Professor Richard
J Samuels Ford international professor
of political science at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology to
travel to the Wilds of New Haven to
speak to us all today
I can honestly think of no active Scala
in any discipline better qualified to
deliver the whole lecture in Japanese
studies
he is a towering figure and I don't mean
just because he's actually like me quite
tall and a former basketball player
although that is also true
um Professor Samuels was born in
Brooklyn and grew up uh just across the
sound uh in Long Island on Long Island
while in high school he met his wife
Deborah who were also extremely pleased
to be able to Welcome to New Haven hi
welcome
[Applause]
um if you're not already familiar with
them I would recommend uh Deborah
Samuels Japanese and Korean cookbooks
which I think are among the very best
available to introduce those Cuisines to
people in English
and I hope you won't mind me saying that
as college students they went to Japan
together for the first time
to Kyushu which is a place that I know
some people here have a special
connection to also
um and then after that initial
experience uh Professor Samuels went on
to complete an M.A at Tufts and then his
PhD at MIT where he has of course gone
on to build an illustrious career
like uh John W Hall Professor Samuels is
very much an institution Builder who has
held many significant leadership roles
not only at MIT where he has served in
many important uh uh uh roles including
as the Director of the center for
international studies but also in
numerous organizations responsible for
stewarding different aspects of U.S
Japan relations in particular including
the Japan U.S friendship commission the
Japan Committee of the national research
Council and the U.S Japan conference on
cultural and educational interchange
the contributions are of course these
contributions are of course more than
matched by his achievements as a scholar
in the age of Wikipedia and indeed chat
GPT there is I think no need for me to
list all of Professor Samuel's important
Publications I suspect chat GPT might
add a few creative ones
um
but given the occasion it would be
remiss of me not to mention that his
1994 book Rich Nation strong Army
National Security and the technological
transformation of Japan was recipient of
the John W Hall prize from the
association of Asian studies for best
book in the field of Japanese studies
among other distinguished prizes
more generally let me say that in an era
in which all disciplines seem to battle
with the curse of over specialization
Professor Samuel's Corpus of scholarly
work speaks not just across subfields
but across disciplines I certainly think
it's true that there's no Japan
political scientist whose work is
assigned in history classes as often as
those of Professor Samuels and part of
the reason for that is simply that he
always takes on topics of clear and
obvious importance
think for example of his books on 311 or
on Japanese Grand strategy
for all of the seriousness with which
Professor Samuels engages the specif
specificities of the of Japan's
political culture moreover he's equally
someone who thinks broadly and
comparatively as perhaps most obviously
evidenced by his path-breaking
comparative study of political leaders
in Japan and Italy Machiavelli's
children
Professor Samuels is also a Wordsmith of
unusual skill and talent whose books are
replete with sentences that make you
smile as well as think
and which are full of smaller Treasures
of wisdom as well as compelling answers
to large questions
finally let me say that Professor
Samuel's work is characterized not only
by a refusal to pull punches but also by
a level of honesty and integrity which
commands respect even from those who
might disagree or take very different
stances on key political questions
his most recent book special Duty a
history of the Japanese intelligence
Community provides an excellent example
of this I'm sure I'm not the only person
who's been forced to rethink their own
preconceptions about issues such as the
controversial 2013 designated States
Secrets sorry I knew I was going to
stumble on this designated States Secret
law as a result of reading that
wonderful book
I've gone on much too long I know but I
hope some of what I've said will help
you understand why I am really excited
to hear Professor Samuel's lecture today
and I hope without that you will now
join with me in welcoming him to the
podium
thanks very much Danny um it's a
pleasure to be here and and it's it's an
honor really to address you this
afternoon
uh not least because the lecture series
pays tribute to one of the Nations and
yells
most distinguished Japan specialist John
Whitney hall
now I'll be speaking about Japan's
response to its security environment uh
this afternoon it's a topic I suspect
that Professor Hall would have found of
interest in a different security
environment but it was certainly a fount
of interest but before I go there I want
to reflect a bit on what brought me to
this topic
and to connect the journey to my mentor
Lucian Lucian pie Steve
you were Lucian was still around when
you were right okay good you'll enjoy
this I hope
um he earned his PhD here at Yale so
it's not entirely inappropriate
for lucian's feshrift my co-editor is
Myron weiner uh
and I asked each of our authors to they
were all comparativists of One stripe or
another
we asked them to reflect on the
political culture of foreign area
studies why why do comparativists some
compare to this pick certain topics and
not others and and what's what's the
political culture that what are the what
are they what are they bathing in
um
our presumption was that Lucian would be
very would have been
very comfortable uh with that namely
that there are academic norms and
academic values that stimulate and
perhaps legitimate some inquiry and and
preclude others
and that was Lucian was very comfortable
with that it turned out a very easy case
to make it was quite clear that the
circumstances of foreign politics uh
uh that they shape our research agendas
that was that was that was not a hard
thing to discover one obvious example
from the chef fishrift session uh was
made by one of his former Solutions
former students who was a specialist on
Soviet politics and who explained uh to
a an understanding audience that that
some of the best uh that that the Soviet
politics contributed very little
um to the literature on political
participation uh duh uh but another was
that some of the best conceptual work on
on social movements and ethnicity came
from the study of South Asia again this
all made perfect sense but but as I dug
into the Japanese case
uh
it was less obvious why with the notable
exception of Chalmers Johnson and maybe
Ronald Dore Japanese
uh contributed so little to political
economic or social theory and why were
we I wondered Theory takers and not
Theory makers why why why didn't we do
what Specialists and other
fields of comparative inquiry did was it
something about us as Japan Scholars
or was it something about Japan
and it was a few short steps from those
questions that that uh that led to a
larger one had we somehow been captured
were we captured Intelligentsia and if
so
who was our our captor or were we slaves
to Convention or uh perhaps to politics
and if it's the latter did we serve our
own Sovereign
politics that was that was driving us
um this is something that John dower
another great Japan specialist and a
colleague of mine at MIT
he once charged that or is it because
they were we were captives to a foreign
Sovereign as the so-called Japan Bashers
of the the 80s and 90s suggested uh did
the considerable resources of uh that
were made available to Japan Specialists
by Japanese sources dampen our
enthusiasm to say critical things about
Japan
did the resources that were made
Available To Us by the U.S government
dampen our enthusiasm to criticize the
United States
in short I found it with notes that with
no small regret that for decades on both
sides of the Pacific of the Pacific War
the political culture of Japanese
political studies in the United States
had corresponded much more directly to
the Ebbs and flows of bilateral
relations with with Japan uh and between
Japan and the United States uh then to
the unfettered intellectual curiosity of
those of us who are studying and our
predecessors who were studying the topic
that is Japanese political studies had
lurched from one to another intellectual
fashion and we likely missed a lot in
the process I know I did I missed a lot
and I'll get to that point immediately
but so let me indulge in sort of a
personal account because it wasn't until
30 years after uh lucian's festrift was
published it was two decades after I
wrote Rich Nation a strong Army uh that
that Danny referred to and at least
seven to eight years after securing
Japan the book on Japan's Grand strategy
came out that I realized that I had
written a two
two books about Japanese National
Security without interrogating two of
the most important topics of that domain
completely ignored how Japan does
intelligence
and I completely ignored
in those two studies the prospects for
Japan's nuclear breakout and acquisition
of nuclear weapons
and indeed in the business of the
Japanese State an earlier book
that that was not on National Security
per se it had a very fat chapter on
nuclear power in the history of the
nuclear power industry in Japan without
ever once my exploring uh what Japan was
planning to do with all that plutonium
uh that it was that it was producing or
why it needed to uh to to have basically
the the the a full cycle nuclear
capability so about a decade ago when it
hit me that I had missed all that stuff
um I began to wonder why I had failed uh
to address those topics and why no one
pointed it out to me and I noticed that
virtually no one else had tackled those
issues either
which is consistent with the point I was
I was starting with here with you so
I've spent the last decade trying to
backfill uh both topics and that brings
me back to uh to Lucian Pi I I wrote a
piece recently for a a really
interesting uh volume that was edited by
Connie ryer and Nora Cottman in Germany
and as I told a group at Columbia
earlier uh well late last year
that that and Charlie knows this well he
was there
um when when passing graduate students
in the hallway
Lucian used to stop the students and ask
invariably are you being brave scholar
are you being brave
and we would all
um non-plus not know exactly how to
respond to such a question it seemed
bizarre to us at the time and we all
smiled and we walked on
but I have never
forgotten the question and I realized
now that he wasn't joking
you need to be brave
because Brave and now certainly Brave
means many things but it appears as a
choice in one form or another at nearly
every stage of of a major project in our
in what we do as academics
um starting with our our choice of
dissertation topics but it's it's easier
to Hue seems to me to disciplinary norms
and to take on subjects that have
already been validated by our mentors
and our peers than it is to get out
ahead of the subfield or even the
discipline and that was that's been
especially the problem in in Japanese
studies it seems to me but in the
current issue of the Texas National
Security review a former colleague of
ours at MIT uh Frank Gavin speaks
directly to this issue and and I want to
just quote him the public-minded scholar
is obliged to disturb the status quo
she should complicate stylized narrative
undermine the conventional wisdom make
people uncomfortable and most of all
force them to challenge the assumptions
and to think
and we all know how to review an
existing literature we know how to
identify a narrow niche in which to
drill down for new information we spend
a lot of time in graduate school
learning how to search for and apply
other people's models we answer other
people's questions but it's much more
difficult and much more risky to
formulate new questions and explore the
previously unexplored in new ways and we
often fail and I have often failed to do
that Solutions Brave Scholars attempt to
hack through the undergrowth of
difficult problems with new tools
and especially with new questions
important questions this is difficult
and it's also risky and as Gavin points
out also very unpopular you don't get to
go to the Garden parties quite as often
um
uh and the risks are greater when the
problem's tougher or when the
conventional wisdom is thicker because
taking risks involves breaking China
small City breaking China
um I'm not here to warmonger but this is
this is because there were rules and
Norms in every field again this is back
to that fish Rift and not least of all
in Japanese studies where rule number
one is decorum
polite be polite observing decorum may
not be difficult but it does constrain
creativity it seems to me
in my own case this challenge was most
clearly manifest when I asked my Todai
onshi my my professor at Tokyo
University for an affiliation with his
new Research Center I was doing Rich
Nations what turned into Rich Nations
strong Army and I wanted to go where The
Cutting Edge of work was being done in
Japan and it was in his Center and he
declined he said no you can't affiliate
uh with with us because he said my topic
was um isn't something he had organized
an important study group on which I knew
of he said it was too sensitive and uh
the guy's upstairs meaning the
bureaucracy
uh wouldn't wouldn't be comfortable with
it and then after situating myself
elsewhere I asked for a copy of the
group's report and he didn't provide it
and since I had followed all the
decorous rules of Japanese studies the
ice
the gift exchanges and the more
substantive accommodations over many
years and since he was supposed to be an
academic
I thought we were in the same business
I was shocked in the event I wrote the
book I wanted to write and and it won
several prizes as Danny kindly said
including the John Whitney all prize
which was was lovely but I found myself
excluded from a range of activities
a range of activities for at least a
decade and solution pies injunction to
be brave which I never saw myself as
understanding before
stayed in my head and it's still there
there are still a lot of questions we
have not thought to ask for a variety of
reasons some of which I've tried to
outline here in my introductory remarks
but if this is even more important it
seems to me uh when as in in political
science methods are getting more at
least I can speak to political science
methods are getting more attention than
substance in some cases so let's turn to
substance if we can and that actually
what was on the poster is the substance
that I want to talk about I think that
students of of National Security uh who
were born after the Asia Pacific War
find it particularly difficult to
suspend disbelief about the prospects
for war
and peace in contemporary Asia
particularly contemporary Japan
and and that's what I'd like to discuss
uh this afternoon not least because uh
the the views of Japan's leaders in
Japanese public opinion have clearly
shifted in in the last decade or two uh
the way Scholars of international
relations get at this is to work
paradigmatically this is this is old
stuff to many of you but it's it's just
useful as a as as a way in which is to
talk about the paradigms uh very very
briefly
um uh so I apologize in advance for
oversimplifying but let me just suggest
that the constructivist the liberal and
the realist perspectives of each had
their day
um in in Japan's post-war Journey uh to
the present
and by the present I'm referring to the
most recent uh announcement of Japan's
New National Security strategy in which
was just in December and I'll just refer
to it going forward now is the NSS
National Security strategy so let me
start by flicking at each of these these
three paradigms just to frame the root
Tokyo has taken uh vis-a-vis the the
alliance with the United States and I'll
start with the constructivist notion uh
that to some post-war Japan has been
pacifist as a matter of national
identity
uh after the war
um you know you're familiar with how
article 9 stipulates that Japan will not
maintain land sea or air forces and you
are no doubt familiar with how Decades
of so-called anti-militarist public
opinion was shaped by the ghosts of
militarist past and this is not untrue
this is actually this constructivist
notion does explain a lot of that I
think I I sometimes refer to the shroud
of of yamakathari Tomo
you're trying to get Japan away from
militarists militarist past and and
pacifism of course was enshrined in law
and declared to be Japan's national
identity uh at least after 1945.
an anti-militarist identity was invoked
to constrain any Japanese military
capabilities particularly offensive ones
like missiles and carriers and Airborne
refueling and things like that the
identity also include the so-called
nuclear allergy which made it impossible
to even imagine
this is where I fell down it made it
impossible to even imagine Japan having
thought about in the acquisition of
nuclear power nuclear weapons but it did
we now know that
and they talk about it openly now but
this identity also included as I say the
nuclear allergy a ban on arms exports an
undersized intelligence capability and a
Prohibition on the on the military use
of space
it seemed that as a result for five
decades or so after the Asia Pacific War
uh
any serious discussion of National
Security was a dangerous third world
third third rail for a an ambitious
Japanese
political candidate
now what I want to do is just shift over
slightly and connect it this this
idea uh into the liberal Paradigm so we
can interrogate this identity more
closely
uh
as you know Japanese conservatives have
governed Japan virtually without a break
since the end of the U.S occupation it's
well understood that this conservative
Camp it's I should say it's less well
understood that this conservative Camp
was never monolithic
and for most of the second half of the
20th century Japan followed the
preferences of its greatest post-war
Statesman which was Yoshida she gated
the ldp was dominated by his wing of the
party which was a very pragmatic uh wing
of the ldp liberal he was not in the ldp
he left politics before the ldp was
formed in November of 55 1955 but his
school
really governed for the most part
for the next 20 30 years
the Yoshida Doctrine his his idea about
National Security was brilliant uh
politically it sustained the pragmatist
power and for the most part kept
military realists who I'll get to in a
moment at arm's length Japan constrained
itself
imposed constraints and sheltered under
U.S protection and invoked its pacifist
identity in doing so it maneuvered
cleverly to avoid entanglement in U.S
Wars and there were many of those
now
it enabled Japan to get back on its feet
without overextending itself through
defense defense spending a conscious
choice
um and it was a choice in from a liberal
perspective of interest groups fighting
with one another about what would drive
the engine of post-war reconstruction
would it be defense has the defense
industry wanted with metis or would it
be uh everything else which is what the
finance ministry wanted it was
everything else
um it made it made economic
Rehabilitation Japan's priority Japan
would remain lightly armed and would
avoid becoming too involved with
International strategic Affairs while
while taking advantage of U.S security
guarantees and getting rich from access
to robust U.S markets and Technology
now politically the greatest benefit was
that the Japanese public
and Japan's neighbors both would be
reassured that Japan no longer posed a
threat to them
to the home to the home uh or or to the
to the neighbors
in exchange Japan would provide the
United States forward basis still does
so Japan's cheap riding was in
everyone's interests and became a
blueprint for Japanese defense and
foreign policy efforts for the next half
century
a scene in this in this liberal View
it was not built on a national identity
rather on a political calculation this
was this was about domestic politics
um and by the early 2000s ldp
pragmatists ran out of steam it seems
and the party's nationalists gained
momentum in their long and very erratic
March uh to uh to consolidating power
and controlling Japan's foreign and
security policies and moreover by this
time
uh domestic squabbles within the ldp had
been overtaken by marked shifts in
Japan's security environment a new world
order was forming so uh given that it's
a new world order imbalance is a power
of changing I mean great segue to the
realist Paradigm
um
even before the the end of the Cold War
Japan had begun to salami slice away
piece by piece slowly the self-imposed
constraints of the oshida doctrine in
the 1980s they extended the sea lions of
chameleons of communication out defense
of the ceilings of communication out a
thousand nautical miles that's not
terribly distant but symbolically very
important in the 1990s they sent
minesweepers to the Persian Gulf after
the conflict ended
um but de facto they had military use of
space by the 2000s they were sending
destroyers to escort tankers to Diego
Garcia to fuel U.S and British war
planes to fight operation enduring
Freedom uh in Afghanistan
and and the salami slicing simply
accelerated it really ramped up in the
2010s and into this this decade
Collective self-defense became possible
reinterpretation of the Constitution to
allow Japan's military to protect the
American Military should come under
under under Fire and under other other
kinds of conditions which we can talk
about but they built a Naval facility in
Djibouti for tens of millions of dollars
they loosened their arms export control
ban self-imposed they created this new
state Secrets law that Danny referred to
that we all got exercised about and
realized that was not such a terrible
thing
again I felt the same way that he did as
I got in as I got into it
um stood up a cyber command they shifted
to Southern defense they stood up a
Marine Corps a Marine Corps
that's an offensive capability last time
I checked and an open discussion of of
the nuclear of a nuclear deterrent
and I haven't even come to the current
NSS yet but I I'm getting there I I
promise I promise you I am by 2021 the
shift uh in East Asia's balance of power
had become very clear uh to Most
Japanese and with that so had the
salience of National Security in
domestic Japanese politics
that year 2021 three of four candidates
for the presidency of the ldp and
therefore for the prime ministership to
succeed sugasan
um uh three of the four of them to be
prime minister emphasized defense issues
and said they were willing to raise the
defense budget I mean this was
a heterodox Beyond repair
um under under earlier assumptions about
Japan's pacifist national identity and
three of the four said they would do
that and the fourth one came in dead
last
okay so this emboldened
um it was a good reading actually of the
public uh public of changes in public
opinion as well clearly Japanese public
opinion on National Security had shifted
um in the direction of broader more
realistic security discourse and we
should credit uh Abe Shinzo uh prime
minister the late prime minister uh with
part of that but of course his
government that is Abe's government
as he was trying to push the Japanese
public into a more realistic posture and
an appreciation for Japan's having a
more realistic pasture had no Little
Help from two provocative neighbors
North Korea and China and as well as
from Washington
and the help from Washington is
counter-intuitive the help from
Washington
um was came from what many Japanese came
to to openly fear was that the United
States would simply not be as committed
uh to defending Japan as it had been
before China's rise and especially
before North Korea acquired
intercontinental ballistic missiles it
changed everything and and so the
confidence in the United States uh
declined
um especially with that first ICBM test
by the by the North Koreans in 2017.
and now by last year the majority of
Japanese polled on these issues viewed
China as a threat and Reporting the
reported feeling and there's a quote
from the survey that U.S influence will
weaken unquote now that's realism 101 uh
in a sense Japan is no longer driving
its security bus with one foot on the
brake it's now become a realist in
realist clothing and this is a this is a
change and what I want to talk about in
the time I have left are three realist
oriented questions that are core to the
U.S Japan Alliance and to Japanese
National Security the first is how far
Japan would go to balance China
the second is how far Japan would go to
defend Taiwan
and the third is to what extent is Japan
hedging against abandonment by the
United States
now to answer these questions it helps
to provide I think more of a feel for
the Contours of Japan's security
environment as articulated in the NSS I
told you I would get there we're here
the new NSS which is the first one in in
a decade
uh uh has attracted a great deal of
attention it's more blunt it's more
ambitious
and it's more muscular than anything
that preceded it and it's also
occasionally as opaque as all the as the
many things that preceded it but by by
far the most remarked upon
um Innovation let's call it military
Innovation is its authorization of the
new standoff missile Counter-Strike
capability uh in making the case for
Counter-Strike which the NSS goes to
Great pains to insist is not in
violation of article 9 of the Japanese
Constitution uh nor Japan's principle of
exclusively defensive defense sensual a
it declares existing bmd about ballistic
missile defense and missile capabilities
simply to be no longer sufficient to
deter
its adversaries its adversaries means
China North Korea
and and uh to deter aggression says the
says the report uh less clear though is
is which missiles will be acquired uh it
looks like it's tomahawks uh and and and
who will do the targeting because Japan
doesn't have uh sophisticated missile
targeting capabilities yet so this is
especially problematic because it's as I
say it's c3i capabilities are 200
developed for the missiles to be
credible as an autonomous deterrent yeah
so that looks like the United States
then
um plays a role uh at least there are
Whispers that the United States military
will play Help play a role in targeting
and close behind the Counter-Strike
decision in media Inc spilled the NSS uh
now formally commits Japan to doubling
its defense budget as a percent of GDP
over the next five years
now it's not clear though how an
underfunded
government of Japan is going to pay for
all this there's a lot that's a lot of
money and so the other thing to note is
note is that there's considerable
opposition inside the government inside
the ldp the ruling the ruling party
um to new taxes
uh this is the you don't want to raise
taxes for this
um they don't want to raise taxes at all
because they want to get reelected and
that's not that's not irrational
um but there's much speculation
therefore that a lot of the spending the
doubling of the GD percentage of GDP
will not be new spending
so
for example there's this uh Wonderful
prestigitation by which the Japan coast
guard and some government-funded dual
use r d budgets are now going to be
swept into the defense budget
but that takes care of a whole hunk of
the increase in defense spending right
there Japan's Coast Guard is a
non-trivial force
and it's not clear how Japan will will
spend whatever funding is actually new
like for the counter the Counter-Strike
capability now third
um the centrality of the alliance in the
NS in the NSF was reaffirmed
um uh and and really earlier than the
NSF was reaffirmed by both countries
even to the point of openly uh
considering the use of combined forces
in in selected contingencies in in
Northeast Asia
Biden Administration loved that
they cheered when the NSS bluntly
referred to China as the this is a quote
from the Nationals
security strategy quote the greatest
strategic challenge to ensuring the
peace and security of Japan and the
International Community I pulled no
punches
uh and uh some in Washington may have
gone hoarse cheering uh it's the
statement in the NSF that Japan must
respond to China's threats to the
rule-based international order in
cooperation with Washington and quote
other like-minded countries we'll get to
those other like-minded countries in a
moment but the it also speaks to the
Strategic use of overseas development
assistance
Aid
us the Strategic use of Aid openly in in
the in the document
presumably in the form of of increased
transfers of military equipment to Naval
vessels for example in aircraft to align
states in southeast Asia
and finally we can see interesting
changes in how Japan's signature cons
interesting changes in Japan's signature
concept of comprehensive security uh is
is characterized some of you are looking
around the room not many of you will
remember that in the 1980s Japanese
strategists associated with Yoshida and
the Yoshida Doctrine invented the term
comprehensive security
to justify low defense spending
because security included economics and
trade and technology and therefore we
shouldn't spend so much money on the
military very interesting concept
um
and and to emphasize Japan's commitments
to diplomacy and foreign Economic Policy
particularly energy policy but today's
NSS speaks instead to not comprehensive
security
but to comprehensive National Power
not the same thing at all and
foregrounds the military alongside the
intelligence community in in the in the
in its in Japan's national security
toolkit
now all this said there was one large
very large dog that didn't bark in any
of this and that's of course I've
referred to several times as a nuclear
Breakout
uh
it didn't bark in the NSS but it did
bark after the Ukraine War started
former prime minister Abe minced no
words within three days a before
of of the uh the the the Russian uh
aggression in into Ukraine Invasion he
called on the government to discuss the
viability of nuclear sharing with the
United States
he said we should have that conversation
uh
but prime minister kishida who by the
way some of you will know is from
Hiroshima uh he uh he he passed on this
and it's his NSS after all now his his
strategy it's his government strategy
his name is on it and it states clearly
that there will be no change to Japan's
three non-nuclear principles
Japan is is and this is a direct quote
from from a really wonderful analysis by
an Israeli an Israeli analyst he said
Japan is the most Salient example in the
world of nuclear hedging among Global
Powers
um and has already as we know openly
embraced the deterrent benefits as they
see it of nuclear latency that is the
nuclear Hedge
okay
in fact a sitting Secretary of Defense
talked about after 311 the need to
maintain nuclear power in order to have
in order to have enough fuel uh and and
weapons-grade materials for nuclear
weapons uh as a signal of latency and
that that was uh uh that was as clear a
statement as you can get
um
but the NSS disingenuously I thought uh
declared its commitment to Arms Control
disarmament and non-proliferation
so it's it's it's it's in that Nether
world of we could do this if we want to
do it we could talk about this in the Q
a but we could do this if we want to do
it we have the technology we have the
equipment we have the the material but
we don't want to do it don't make us do
it
but but don't play with us because we
could do it and so forth you get the
idea so nuclear Armament even if it's
German style uh
german-style nuclear sharing has been
left for another day I don't think it's
entirely I can't imagine that it's
entirely off the agenda if my reading of
a Japanese concern about American
commitment and capabilities is is
correct
so from a realist perspective nowhere is
the shift of the regional balance of
power in China's favor potentially more
consequential for Japan than Taiwan to
get to that second issue I wanted to
raise which sits along the first island
chain of the Strategic choke point for
Naval forces in the Western Pacific and
is critical to securing Japan's Southern
flag
Tokyo a very long cautious in offering
overt support to Taiwan issued a defense
white paper in 2021 declaring that Japan
will quote play pay close attention to
the taiwan's situation with a sense of
Crisis unquote
and that was followed by a series of
2021-2022 trial balloons that were sent
up by senior Japanese defense officials
who proclaimed that Japan has to defend
Taiwan will have to defend Taiwan
I could give you the quotes but for this
I won't I won't go into them they're all
basically that message
um
so it wasn't a huge surprise that the
NSS went bold on this
although it declares this no change to
the 1972 Japan China communique or to
its relationship with Taiwan the NSS
stresses that Japan and Taiwan share
values quote unquote and labels Taiwan
quote an extremely important partner and
dear friend
now these developments are striking but
given that Japan has no treaty
obligation to defend Taiwan
and given the economic Stakes embedded
in the China relationship which are
considerable China is Japan's largest
single trading partner
um
I guess that some Japanese prime
ministers like yishida would hesitate
ordering the SDF to fight
in support of U.S forces in the Taiwan
contingency until or unless there are
there are the Japanese civilians or
soldiers fall to hostile fire
so we'll watch the space and remind
ourselves that just a few years ago even
a even a general discussion of these
shifts and plans would have ensured a
government crumbling Thunderclap
this time
crickets
now this is possible for for two not
unrelated reasons
first because the U.S foreign policy has
been feeding an abandonment discourse no
other way to describe it is an
abandonment discourse in Japan now for
several years and second because the
center of gravity of Japanese public
opinion has shifted to the right
to test this uh
very crudely I'm not known as a
methodologist
but to test this very crudely I took a
quick look at how the Ragged U.S
withdrawal from Afghanistan in August of
uh uh
2021 was connecting to the Japanese
conversation about Taiwan
and about a Taiwan contingency and I
found hundreds of thousands of links in
a Japanese Google search to stories
links to stories asking questions like
will Taiwan be like Afghanistan
uh will Japan also be abandoned uh by
the United States
the the the the American withdrawal from
Afghanistan galvanized attention in
Japan and predictably very predictably
the crisis in Ukraine further stimulated
these concerns so what was a low boil of
concern about American
commitment and capabilities and really
happy talk among alliances at formal
meetings like two plus twos and so forth
what was the low boil began to Bubble
really quite vigorously and so when I
did the same Google search but
substitute after the Ukraine crisis
began
um Google returned twice the number of
hits that it did on the Afghanistan
question and sifting through hundreds of
them it was clear to me that many
Japanese were fretting about whether
failed U.S support for Ukraine might
undermine extended deterrence in
Northeast Asia
so let's take a look at this concern and
take on that third question that I
mentioned which is what is Japan doing
about it by training about about this by
hedging uh Japanese hedging is a classic
realist question but the blunt virgin
blunt version is that while Japanese
leaders know that the U.S Alliance is
their best bet there's no question about
that
um Tokyo has been nonetheless actively
hedging for some time and is doing so
more actively these days with very broad
public support and ironically with U.S
encouragement it's very interesting the
Russian invasion of Ukraine made it very
easy for Japan's hedging inclined
realists just months ago the the chief
of the ground self-defense Force as well
the former Chief of the ground
self-defense forces the Army the
Japanese Army made a very succinct case
for the connection between the Ukraine
war and further discussions of a nuclear
weapons option
the former Chief of the of the Japanese
military he said quote the world learned
from Ukraine that the United States will
not intervene militarily in the event of
a possible nuclear war
that we were deterred from getting in by
Russia's possession and and Putin's
you know Putin's Behavior declarations
and capabilities so besides its
agreements
with Washington uh Japan now has two
plus twos that that's defense and State
the defense of foreign ministers meeting
together bilaterally with five countries
it has it has acquisition and
cross-servicing agreements the axes with
four juiceomias which are intelligence
sharing agreements with seven countries
bilateral military training with eight
different countries and has Inc defense
equipment transfer agreements with five
different countries and in recent years
there's been a noticeable increase in
the exercises and Port visits to Japan
by countries
that are not the United States of
America from Japan's perspective this is
designed to keep major States on side
and Neighbors on side vis-a-vis China
and to hedge against what the mod Think
Tank vmod Think Tank meaning nids the
National Institute for defense studies
uh openly has identified as the like
quote likely shrinking of U.S relative
power in a multi-polar order
now some initiatives are more robust or
more modest I should say than others but
there have been developments of note
that have proceeded in parallel with a
tightened hug of the United States
so I'm going to just quickly flick at
them and I'll get out of your way but
the one that has attracted the most
attention is the quad
known as the quad which comprises the
United States Australia Japan and in
India four countries that share concerns
about and and seek and seek uh
uh to counter China's assertive behavior
in the indo-pacific it's a vast area of
course through which the world's exports
and more than a third of its Global
Imports are Transit now this is not a
NATO by any it's not a mini NATO Mini Me
by any any extent but quad meters quad
leaders do hold regularly scheduled uh
strategic consultations and joint
military exercises it's the beginning of
something bigger in it seems anyway
there are important bilateral
initiatives as well last year Tokyo and
and Canberra signed a reciprocal access
agreement to establish the two countries
Defense Forces to cooperate with each
other for the first time enhance
Partnerships with European States
including the Brits who train annually
now with the Japanese ground
self-defense force in Japan last year
Tokyo and London signed a reciprocal
access agreement modeled on the one with
Australia yeah and perhaps the biggest
and for U.S defense contractors the most
unwelcome news was the agreement signed
late last year by by the UK Italy and
Japan all three Partners in the Lockheed
Martin F-35 program to form a new
partnership of equals quote unquote to
develop a sixth generation fighter
platform
for the Japanese and for the first time
a Japanese combat plane will not be
purchased
co-developed or co-produced
with the United States
now for its part France with has two
million Nationals in in and eight eight
thousand military personnel in the
indo-pacific has strengthened its ties
with Japan and even Germany which you
wouldn't think of as having anything to
defend necessarily out in the in the in
the uh
uh in the east in the South China Sea
and so forth it has no Pacific
territories in the South down in the
Philippine Sea anyway it delighted many
in Japan by sending a frigate uh to
Northeast Asia and telling the press
this is the thing that really got people
excited wasn't the frigate frigate
didn't impress many people certainly not
China
um but that saying publicly that China
cannot be allowed to impose their own
order in the region it's the Germans
and of course none of these
relationships compares to the U.S
Japanese or even to the Australia
Japanese uh security ties but it's worth
noting how security stopped being a
third rail for aspiring Japanese leaders
as China's power grew in as America's
power has declined uh relatively so let
me end by by returning to the to the
liberal Paradigm for a second and speak
to the divisions within the Japanese
strategic Community regarding National
Security
although his cabinet is responsible for
the new NSS as I've said uh prime
minister kishida is not a military
realist in the Abe mold
indeed we recall that he became prime
minister over Abe's objections
opposition and therefore felt it
necessary as a matter of political logic
he can count uh faction faction numbers
um and and felt it necessary as a matter
of political logic to accept a harder
line NSS than he was usually associated
with
um after he was he was considered dovish
in the Yoshida pragmatic in the Yoshida
School
this was a struggle for him for a time
he and his supporters took pains to
remind voters that China was Japan's
largest trading partner and right after
taking office in late 2021 uh Mr kishia
declared his government would make an
effort to stabilize relations with
Beijing immediately stepping into office
he sees the opportunity to insert a more
China moderate party Chief animal China
moderate foreign minister who actually
had chaired the China Japan friendship
parliamentary friendship committee for
four years that got some that got
people's attention so it was a reminder
in a way but he still went went along
with a Hardline NSS so this is a
reminder that a range of Visions among
Japanese strategists persists even
within the LEP
now the military the military realism
that seems to have prevailed in the
production of the new NSS remains one of
only four
uh Grand strategic choices and some of
you will have heard me I I hope or I'll
have read that I've written about this
in the past I'll just very briefly flick
but these realists are the folks who
that the realists are the folks who know
they can't balance China alone and while
claiming to be all in with the United
States have been busy developing all
uh busy diversifying Japan's dependence
on on Washington but there are also band
wagoners bandwagoners with China
in Japan mostly in the business
Community who would prefer the Japan
accommodate to Chinese power
and uh they see China as the new Global
leader
and U.S Us's time has passed and their
numbers have dwindled as China has
overplayed its hand
frankly in the region
um
but their view is not irrelevant and
just last fall the vice vice chair of
Japan's one of Japan's leading business
associations uh the case some of you
know this organization made headlines
I'm going to read you a quote
he when he declared that over the course
of history the world's hegemon
has changed from the Netherlands to
Great Britain to the United States and
now China is up for the challenge we are
at a major turning point in in world
history Japanese companies should not
make a hasty decision to withdraw from
China it was a perfect reflection of
this view that I'm trying to communicate
to you now a third strategic perspective
is espoused by dual hedgers people who
want to have their cake and eat it too
like yishida before he moved rightward
as a matter of political protection that
as I've described it
to try to keep the the military realists
at arm's length these folks think that
neither all in bandwagoning with China
nor all independence upon the United
States
U.S which is in relative decline are
really in Japan's interests so they
would like to have it both ways and
finally there are those who want Japan
to keep its distance epox on both houses
keep its distances from its distance
from both Washington and Beijing they
prefer autonomous defense
and would like to have Japan use the U.S
Japan Alliance
as a means
to transcend the U.S Japan Alliance
now like the bandwagoners the autonomous
fly beneath most radars but if you want
a taste and I urge you to have a taste
of of the autonomy argument I suggest
you read the several daily tweets that
are put out by
tamilgami toshio you'll remember he was
the former air self-defense Force Chief
of Staff who was who was fired in 2008
for insisting that Japan's aggression in
in in Northeast and Southeast Asia in
the 1930s and 40s was for a just cause
his position was not marginal it was
certainly not what the Japanese
government espoused was National policy
so he was he was fired Kuby he he's gone
but he then ran for governor of Tokyo
and got 16 of the vote that's not it's
not a majority it's not even close to
you couldn't form a government but he
got 16 of the vote so this is a part of
the Japanese security discourse we can't
underestimate the point is is not only
that diversity in Japanese strategic
thinking oh I should say he tweets I
think I did say he tweets all the time
have a look it's it's very interesting
stuff
and the point is not only that diversity
in Japanese strategic thinking is alive
and well but also that each of these
strategic choices requires Japan to get
its relationship
just right with Washington and Beijing
and that's that's what I elsewhere
called the the Goldilocks uh challenge
uh to Japan to get it just right and I'd
be happy to explore that further in Q a
but let me stop here I've gone on too
long thank you very much for your
attention
hi thank you professor
a really interesting talk
um it kind of struck me at a certain
point when you were discussing Japan's
extensions
looking for other partners
in
information collecting and perhaps
defense Services
um the kind of complete lack of
discussion of South Korea and how these
changes over Taiwan have impacted the
South Korean Japanese relationship and I
was wondering if you could speak to that
point no it's it's great and and I I
just felt like I had to cut off
something somewhere and you've you
nailed it I did not talk about the
career I talked about North Korea only
in passing and and there's been
the relationship between
South Korea and Japan hit a new rock
bottom over the last five to seven years
it's never been so I mean it has been so
bad but a new post 1965 Rock Bottom 65
was the normalization of relations and
like that
um and
part of it
um
part of it is due to the fact that there
are actors in both countries who are
basically the skunks in the garden party
and and any
uh
any effort to have some level of
reconciliation runs into their these
politicians either ideological or
electoral Logics of of
using the other country the the right
wing in Japan and the left wing in Korea
as uh
as foils for their own for their own
base and and uh so
there's that there's the the fact that
that the the
well you know obviously the hist the
history issue right we call it your
historian you know about this the
history issue
um uh has has been used in that way in
both countries the Japanese by denying
much of their history and and the the
South Koreans by inflating
in some cases some of some of the
history but it's hard to inflate the the
uh the violence that was brought to uh
to Korea by the Japanese in any event
the uh there was there was a lot uh
there was a lot wrong with the
relationship but so long as the Korean
electorate sent uh a left-wing
government to power
and maintained a military realist
government at home
uh it was it was uh it was a recipe for
for not disaster disaster is way too
strong but it was a recipe for
significant deterioration in the
relationship and that's now changed with
the election of of President Yoon
uh and the willingness of a more
moderate
kishida more moderate than say Abe was
on this issue to try to find a solution
um I think people give the United States
credit
for you know knocking heads together we
have two treaty allies out there they
don't get along with one another they
don't share intelligence with one
another and they have the same
adversary in north in North Korea
I don't think that that the United
States deserves the credit that it's
getting I think I think the the Korean
electorate and the Japanese electorate
deserve the credit uh for this but we'll
see how far it goes because there are
skunks and in at that garden party I'm
not sure if that gets but but there's
there are many levels to the hostility
between Korea and Japan some of them
again rooted in history but some are
quite contemporary
thanks I mean it's a great question it's
exactly what I didn't talk about I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
more about uh Japan's plutonium stocks
in terms of I mean this is really a
Break
um in the nuclear Taboo in many ways
that was taken
um without knowledge perhaps or or the
ascent of the Japanese public I was
wondering where you see that
um sort of stockpile and desire to
create a breakout capability started
coming into place especially since you
know you think things like when when the
PRC tested its first nuclear device
during the Tokyo Olympics I mean that
became you know rather serious uh
diplomatic crisis right so you know
where do you see this kind of shift
taking place over time it's a it's
another good question the um
we are seeing now in the there are there
are two
uh two papers that I know of
um that have written by Scholars who
have gone into the archives and have
found that there was an awareness of
what was judged then
and still is now to be the benefits of
nuclear latency all the way back into
the 1950s and 60s
and so the decision to to go forward
with nuclear power was a decision taken
in the with the understanding that there
would be a collateral benefit
uh which is uh
a a viable latency uh viable nuclear
hedge so in the form of those plutonium
stockpiles so where are they
um a lot of them uh went off to to the
French and the British and and so forth
for reprocessing and so forth but but
you know these were all and some people
say well it's you know it's in the
possession of the Japanese uh nuclear
power front the Japanese Electric
utilities but a lot of it is not and and
uh you know Japan has worked very hard
to establish itself as the Paragon of
disarmament non-proliferation and so
forth but it's it's a it's you know with
apologies to those of you in in Japanese
who study Japanese Fine Arts but it's a
bit of a kabuki
um when 311 happened as I mentioned
before Morimoto who was the the the El
the dpjs a minister of defense said no
we need we need this stuff
um as a nuclear threat ishiba shigado a
former uh
Minister of Defense from the ldp
likewise said we need this we must not
stop nuclear power and they campaign
very hard for this now my favorite story
on this so the Japanese have kept the
door wide open
to be really clear and have defended an
open door for for the reasons for the
reasons that with the basic reasons they
think it's a deterrent and it may well
be maybe
my favorite story about this was a story
I read in a Japanese it actually was an
American Magazine
uh I think it was Forbes or Fortune it
was it was a sort of a high-end business
magazine and and
it was an interview with an unnamed
Japanese military official
who uh
was asked by the reporter
um how uh how long will it take Japan to
become
nuclear-armed how long would breakout
actually take
and the the reporter wrote
that his interlocutor threw up his hands
and said we have absolutely no plans to
do anything like that
but if we did it would be 186 days
exactly six months
and so you know you have this
you you you you you have this option and
that's all it is right now and and and
actually Fielding a nuclear weapon comes
in many forms and the German one we
talked about still has the United States
with its foot on the neck uh and but
there are other options as well the
British option option here renting
nuclear weapons is all sorts of things
and I think
depending upon how well the United
States does in convincing the Japanese
not to be
excessively concerned about its
commitment and its capabilities going
forward you won't see much much movement
toward nuclear breakout in the near term
but in the mid and long term I don't
think they have much of an option
frankly
thank you for a very interesting talk my
question is uh
how do you see
uh the new Japanese defense
posture jiving with
its demographic transition that is
very good good question I'm going to go
back to uh
did everyone understands it's the
demographic transition of Japan it's a
great question and and it's one you have
to think about if you study if you study
this stuff I'm going to go back to
tamogami it's my favorite right wing uh
interlocutor indirectly as it is it's
I've never met the man
um he he published some data yesterday
two days ago from densu
so it's a major Japanese public
relations company
and it reported that 13 a little over 13
percent of the of Japanese uh were
willing to fight in a in a war for Japan
and then he compared that to 80 percent
of the Chinese who are willing to fight
for China in a war now
not only is that an enormous Gap in
relative terms
but if you if you factor in the fact
that Japan is you know a hundred and
what is 120 30 million now and China is
God knows three point
one point three four huge and so in in
absolute numbers
it's an extraordinarily large gap
demographic app
um of not just of
of young people but of people willing to
fight and die for their country and they
have no conscription
so
um I think uh and and they're and
they're they're leaving billets unfilled
on a regular basis they are just not
filling their recruiting targets not by
a long shot is maybe a hundred thousand
eighty to a hundred thousand I'm I think
I think I'm making up those numbers but
I don't think I'm off by an order of
magnitude there's an enormous shortfall
of of
in recruitment so I think it is a
serious problem and and one way around
that of course is to use a military
equipment that's not manned
and so and and the Japanese understand
that so they're they're buying more
unmanned aerial Vehicles the more
missile systems and so forth but that's
not going to get them where they want to
go
um in a major conflict especially if
it's a conflict that involves the United
States and the U.S wants and needs uh
boots on the ground
which is what Richard Armitage asked for
the last time
but it's a it's a good question it's a
real problem
yes thank you Professor Samuels for
sharing your insights with us
um
prime minister kishida visited uh Kiev
recently when
um president XI was in Moscow
that's that's a major signal obviously
is that something that may divert some
resources from uh the Ukraine front to
Eastern Russia or the Russians don't
care
at this stage
I'm not sure I get what is the diversity
with Russia see this as a recent to
divert resources from the Ukraine war or
is I don't I don't think so I I think
what what the Prime Minister was doing
and you know you know color me cynical
but he's got the G7 coming up
and he's chairing it and it's in Japan
and he can't really have the authority
he would otherwise have
as chair of the G7 meeting if he didn't
get to Kiev since every one of the other
leaders did and so I think that's that's
the cynical part of me I don't see a
shift
in the the deployment of forces that
results from any of this in fact I don't
think he has the authorization
in the political
juice
to make that happen yet
but I I think he and he really was
desperate to get over there before the
G7 got started it was it was it was
clearly all Politics on that one I think
domestic policy well International
politics but he wants the Japanese
people to understand he's a whoops he's
a world leader too
thank you very much for this talk
Professor I think you mentioned the
number of 168 days to to achieve a
nuclear weapon for Japan and it wouldn't
it's really a quick process and I want
to ask what would be the Chinese
reaction to any signal from Japan to
achieving a nuclear weapon if any
Japanese step to this direction will
push China to a war in Taiwan
great question the the
the
first of all I I don't believe that 186
day
um is is a reliable number
um but uh it was the no it was the
answer that was quoted I I think this
the Japanese have a lot to do
um a lot in addition to do but we don't
know because so much of it is shrouded
so okay let's say if it's not six months
it'll be uh it could be a year or year
and a half that's still very short
um what would be the Chinese reaction
uh
predictably uh very severe
I would think
um now the question is what does that
mean does it does it mean uh an attack a
preemptive attack I I don't think so
um because Japan has a nuclear-armed
uh treaty partner in the United States
so I don't imagine that that there'd be
a preemptive attack in the event that
that a nuclear program is is unveiled
um I'm sorry
oh an attack on Taiwan
and you're asking about whether the
Japanese would use nuclear weapons in
the event
if China
will want to attack Taiwan before the
Japanese have their nuclear ability
no I don't think so I don't I don't
think that that would that would do it
because I think the the Chinese
um have a bigger uh adversary to contend
with and one more likely to get into a
fight and that's the United States so I
think the calculation on on whether or
not you know they do it before the
Japanese can become a nuclear power is
is probably not high on the on the
agenda yeah I see the question now good
thanks so much for the very interesting
talk I wanted to ask you uh if you could
speak a little bit more about how Japan
is going to pay for the defense budget I
thought it was really interesting I
hadn't heard about now we can count the
Japan coast guard as part of the defense
budget that gets part of the way there
I'm wondering about what your thoughts
about how they get the rest of the way
there but also I'm wondering how much
you see the success of pledges like this
where the NSS more generally as tied to
the fate of kishita so kishida doesn't
seem like particularly popular the
policies might be popular but he's he's
not necessarily that popular with the
public right now do you see these
policies as popular enough within the
public and the ldp that even if kishida
were to say you know not last long
enough to implement them they'll
probably go on without him or I just
curious how much you see it is tied to
kishida's own political future yeah and
and I think actually kishida has been
bold on this one in a way that
I wouldn't have expected in the sense
that he's been in favor of tax increase
whereas others have said Let's do let's
let's sell bonds we'll we'll make the
children and grandchildren and
foreigners pay for this I think
um and uh but he he went for the tax
increase uh but he's not got the support
that he needs he's not got the support
he needs for that so how do you get
there well it's not just the Coast Guard
remember it's it's also
um any government funding for uh dual
use are dual use Technologies and that
you know that's a big tent
that's that's a huge tent because almost
everything is a dual use technology
according to its proponents you know it
it's it's the people who who are looking
for the funding right so let's do use
um and I you know it would be
interesting to to actually do some back
of the envelope at least back at the
envelope calculations on how far that
gets them but it it's it's clearly not
far enough because they're still talking
about tax and bonds and um there may be
some perhaps some
uh
agreement reached some kind of a
negotiated settlement reached between
the advocates for each but I I sort of
doubt it that the ldp has had nothing
but as you know Charlie the ldp has had
nothing but trouble every time it raises
taxes it gets hammered by voters
hammered and so it's not only they don't
want to fight and die for their country
they don't want to pay taxes
either they already do pay tax pay a lot
of taxes they don't want to pay more
taxes so I think he's he's in a bind
um but I I got the impression that that
his popularity has improved in the last
couple three weeks and I think getting
over to key back to back to that
question from the gentleman up here
um getting to Kiev and demonstrating
leadership of this sort will further
reinforce and maybe even lead to an
early uh dissolution of diet and and the
re-election so that's my guess is the
calculation there
am I able to can I ask uh so there you
are thank you very much for a wonderful
talk and and I was trying to think of a
brave question but I'm a comparative
assistant I'm gonna ask about uh voters
and this is actually a perfect follow-up
I think to to Charlie's question because
I was also interested in the payment for
for these new programs or for the
expansion of the defense budget
um and I know the IR Scholars are
interested in in what syncs battleships
and and we're interested in what sinks
the ldp uh and so I'm I'm curious right
if the current Trend among Japanese
leaders is realist
can we construe public opinion can we
construe the the voters as well as
realists or merely realist accommodating
for now and that is to say when push
comes to shove is everybody a realist
until they come for your pension it's
like the uh everyone's a liberal until
they get mugged right right
um yeah no uh okay I I don't know the
answer to that except to say except to
report to you something you already know
Colin which is that the keep doing that
that the Japanese voters
um now report
uh support they're not just
accommodating to Abe they're actually
supporting military realist programs and
postures they it seems to me real a real
shift at the center of gravity has moved
in in Japanese public opinion and that
it's a real thing and um
but you know this also it's also true in
the United States that everybody is you
know let's let's go fight this war we we
do this all the time until it's your
children uh or your neighbor's children
and then you're not so enthusiastic
anymore right so uh or it shouldn't be
anyway uh so um I I think that um
I think it's I think it's a real change
I guess is the this is the bottom line
it's it's substantive it's real it's
calculable
um and uh
I think sustainable China China's just
been as I said overplaying its hand
China had it could have achieved so much
more
by not being as provocative as it's been
in the region and and uh
now
during the Abe Administration uh Abe
goes to Beijing and he talks to Xi
Jinping and they work out a whole list
of of economic agreements is October now
of 2018 I think right
um and they work out a whole set of
agreements and it looked like you know
that Abe had moved to the center from
the right as it turned out nothing ever
took place nothing ever happened it was
all for show and so uh the the real the
reality is everyone has moved to the
right in Japan
thank you so much for your wonderful
talk so my question is on so you
mentioned how the overall business
sector of Japan right now favors
increasing bit trade interactions with
China and I want to know how
um to what extent it represents
the
the sentiment the concept the perception
of the general public the small business
owners especially tourism and tourism or
it represents the Wilderness of the
elite cross the big companies and to
what extent can this
business oriented sentiment impact the
policy making of of the Japanese
government yeah I mean I think business
is more divided I mean
what I was trying to get at was that
there is a part of business like the
case spokesperson
who sees China as the future and so
forth but I think business is quite
divided on China there are those who are
dependent upon imports from China like
uh Rare Earth
Metals For example who were denied
access to them and then had to hustle to
find alternative sourcing and so forth
do the political political bilateral
political disputes right so you have you
have uh
in a sense the Japanese
business Community
um is is split between those who
built Big factories in China and want
them to succeed in enormous Capital
Investments and those who are trying to
extract
certain raw materials
the the people who are at the top of the
value added chain will not necessarily
have the same set of interests vis-a-vis
trade with China as the bottom of the
value-added chain I only offered the
example I offered to illustrate one
particular corner of the security
discourse I don't think it represented
all of Japanese business it represented
those who are really who really see it
as China as the future but that's not
everyone
um thank you so much for the talk so um
I have a question about the underlying
causes of the
or the change of public opinion about
the military policies because it seems
at least to me that the reason for the
reason for the change is not limited to
how the Japanese like light-wing
partition
emphasize the like China three discourse
but also it can be attributed to the
loss of public listeners of once both
pacifist movement so I would like to ask
for for what Legend the Japanese
pastries activists
came to lose the public disc of public
business that they once have well I
think that as I said in my remarks there
were three reasons one was that
um
for many Japanese citizens
they recognized that that China was a
security threat to Japan that they came
to see it as Abe was painting it and and
the Abe group the military realists that
I described and so they they understood
that
um that's kind of a highfalutin view
because not everybody in you know in the
Japanese public
sees things in this these kinds of
strategic terms but there are the three
strategic reasons one is that North
Korea I mean it's throwing Hardware over
the archipelago and and nuclear missiles
and he's been doing it for 10 12 years
now and and it's very provocative and so
that they see that as a threat so North
Korea is a threat they see China as uh a
threat and and you know there's a lot of
uh of fuss uh over the Strategic
importance of a very unstrategic bit of
land which is the the senkakas I mean
senkaku islands are inside the first
island chain
if the Chinese get the senkaku islands
they still can't get out of the first
island chain
like if they get Taiwan it you know all
bets are off
and then they're out into the Philippine
Sea but so it's it's it's the threat
from China as they see it the threat
from North Korea as they see it and as I
say uh the demonstrable threat of the
Americans not caring much president
Trump made it very clear you know within
two within a week after his uh
inauguration he he bailed out on the on
the TPP the trans-pacific partnership
um and what do we get this week the
British joined the trans-pacific
partnership they left brexit they left
you know the EU and they joined the
trans much bigger Market
um and the Americans are left out in the
cold to these bilateral ftas and so
forth anyway the the point is the
Americans in the Trump Administration
there was the the dropping of the TPP
uh uh which you know it you know for
domestic political reasons which we can
talk about number one the demands that
that that host Nations support be double
tripled you know and and really telling
the Japanese that they're only good for
you know that we're only there to be
mercenaries and we'll fight for you but
you got to pay us a lot more money
just didn't understand the Strategic
issues didn't care
and he was he was he was doing that
um uh and uh of course after the
uh after his first visit to Korea he was
very North Korea visit with I should say
Kim Jong-un
um I guess in Singapore that summer
uh he made it very clear that he
the United States didn't care about
medium-range nuclear weapons they cared
about intercontinental ballistic
missiles
and so the result was he's and and he
said it out loud
well of course you know if you're
Japanese you know you care about both
you know you should and and you feel
quite abandoned by the United States
when you when you get a president of the
United States saying such things so
there's there's those are the three
strategic reasons and I think they just
have been fed a steady diet of of news
about the sencoccus I mean you know
those poor goats on the Senco Islands a
lot of goats there but that's about
that's about it anyway
this they're fed a steady diet about
about imminent aggression
and you know on some of its sticks
so some as we've seen in the United
States you know there's some of the most
outrageous and Outlanders things stick
and uh you got to deal with it
politically at home
thank you for the interesting talk so I
have a question I wonder I'm curious to
know the role of electoral polit uh
electoral competition in determining
foreign policy in Japan so maybe I
missed it in the talk but are there any
factions in ldp and do different parties
have different scenes um on this on
China threat a non-forign policy in
general
um yeah yeah no yes the answer is yes
and yes the ldp
um
since it's in since its initiation in
the 1950s has been split between a
nationalist Wing in in the book I call
them the revisionist way but it's a
national they wanted to revise the
Constitution but it's really it should I
should have called it the Nationalist
win which was Kishi
Abe's grandfather and nakasone
and those those guys
um and the pragmatists under Yoshida
Shigeru and and his followers and you
know there was the pragmatists were
they they were pragmatic and and they
didn't do things to inflame the
bilateral relationships
um in in foreign policy in the way that
the nationalists would and in fact it's
it's curious because from an American
perspective it seemed
um that there's no there was no better
friend to the United States than kishina
usuke
which is very very ironic since he was a
you know an unindicted war criminal
spent time in tsugamo prison he was
ave's grandfather and um but you know he
was anti-communist that was good enough
for us during the Cold War
so there are those two big groups now
there are
factions which are not all policy
defined
there's there's leadership so for
example you get someone like also a
former prime minister and former Vice
Prime and Deputy Prime Minister and so
forth he's got all sorts of people in
his faction they're not all military
realists and um uh and and those
factions matter and we saw how much they
mattered when Abe
ordered his faction or signaled to his
faction that it should not support
kishida and he had to Cobble together
support from the rest of the factions to
get become president of the party and
then prime minister so these things do
matter and the kishida folks as I
described them in my remarks
um are these uh dual hedgers who would
like to have it both ways they they
um they think that they can
and so
kishida comes out of that Yoshida school
and and is um is identified with a much
uh more moderate
approach to China historic over the last
state he was foreign minister you know
so so while he was foreign minister it
was a much more uh deliberate pragmatic
approach which didn't I don't think
transform it didn't transform Chinese
behavior and as I say I think the
Chinese
said it several times already I won't
repeat it but but they miscalculated
please
thank you Professor Samuels for his
Grim but enlightening
thank you
foreign
[Music]